قال ايضا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن ان الولايات المتحده تعتقد ان دعوه
الاباده الجماعيه التي رفعتها جنوب
افريقيا ضد اسرائيل في محكمه العدل
الدوليه لا اساس لها واضاف بلينكن بعد
اجتماعه بقاده اسرائيل بمن فيهم رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو في تل ابيب ان
هذه الدعوه تصرف العالم عن الجهود المهمه
من اجل السلام
والامن
نواصل الوقوف مع اسرائيل حتى لا تتكرر
هجمات السابع من اكتوبر مره اخرى كما انني
ركزت بشكل مكثف على اعاده الرهائن
المتبقين ومعالجه الازمه الانسانيه وتعزيز
حمايه المدنيين في غزه ومنع الصراع من
التوسع وهذا هو السبب وراء عملنا بشكل
عاجل لصياغه طريق نحو السلام والامن
الدائمين لهذه المنطقه ونحن نعتقد ان
تقديم شكوى ضد اسرائيل في محكمه العدل
الدوليه يصرف العالم عن كل هذه الجهود
الهامه علاوه على ان تهمه الاباده
الجماعيه بلا
اساس